[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SUZIE: Hey dad, have
you got a second?
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh hi ya, Suzie.
I always have time for
my favorite daughter.
SUZIE: Aw.
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
TODD KERPELMAN: She'll be fine.
You were saying?
SUZIE: Well, Mark and I have
been codeveloping my app
for a while now.
TODD KERPELMAN: You
and Mark have spending
an awful lot of time together.
[AUDIENCE GOES WOO]
SUZIE: Well, yesterday he
suggested we add the Core Plot
library to my app, and I'm just
not sure we're ready for that
yet.
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
TODD KERPELMAN:
Well, good for you.
Don't let any boys pressure you
into incorporating frameworks
you're not ready for, no
matter how long you've
been codeveloping.
SUZIE: Yes, sir.
I just-- I wish that
there was some way
to try a library
before installing it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Why, as a
matter of fact, there is.
Have you heard about Pod Try?
SUZIE: Pod Try?
What's that?
TODD KERPELMAN: Pod
Try is a low commitment
way of trying out any
demo project associated
with a CocoaPod.
Just imagine.
[HARP]
If you run Pod Try on
a third party library,
CocoaPods will go out to that
library set of project files,
usually on GitHub,
but not always,
and download them to a temporary
directory on your computer.
Once there, it will
scan them for anything
that looks like an Xcode
project or workspace, preferably
in a directory named something
like demo or example.
Now if it finds one, Pod Try
will open that project in Xcode
so you can see how it works.
[HARP]
SUZIE: Oh.
So I could use that to try out
Core Plot without adding it
to my app first?
TODD KERPELMAN: You betcha.
In fact, let's give Pod
Try a try right now.
[LAUGHTER]
Bring on over that
mechanized workstation.
So we know the name for
our CocoaPod is Core Plot.
SUZIE: Yep.
And I remember the search
trick that you showed Robbie.
TODD KERPELMAN: Aw, atta girl.
So all you need to do is
type pod try core plot.
SUZIE: Oh, but wait.
I'm not in my Xcode
project or anything.
Does it matter which
structure I'm in?
TODD KERPELMAN: Nope.
CocoaPods will put this
in a temporary directory
so you don't need
to worry about it.
SUZIE: OK.
So I'm going ahead and
type pod try core-plot.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's right.
Now you can see that CocoaPods
is downloading the GitHub
directory and looking for
any Xcode projects it finds.
If it finds more than
one, it might ask you
which one to open.
But it looks like in our
case, it only found one.
And a few moments later--
[AUDIENCE GASPS]
--Xcode starts up with
our sample ready to go.
Now you go ahead and
run it, make changes,
and fool around with the code
just like any other project.
SUZIE: Golly, that's swell.
So Pod Try will work
with all libraries?
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, not all.
Some developers, they
don't know about Pod Try.
And their sample
apps haven't been
tested to see if they work.
I've noticed
sometimes I need to go
into these temporary directories
and manually run pod update
to get everything working.
[LAUGHTER]
Some developers, they'll
update their library,
and then they'll forget
to update the sample
app that goes along with them.
Whoops.
[LAUGHTER]
And some libraries
like the Google Sign
In library will require you to
replace a couple of constants
to get everything working.
SUZIE: Oh, but does
that mean I can
run Pod Try on any of the
official Google CocoaPods,
and it will open a sample up?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yep.
Now that Google is making
CocoaPods its primary way
of distributing
libraries on iOS,
they're bundling all of
their sample applications
in the same git repository
as the library themselves.
So it's easy to Pod Try them.
They're also making
these sample apps
part of their continuous
integration test process.
So you'll be pretty confident
that they will compile.
SUZIE: I wish I could say
the same about Mark's code.
[LAUGHTER]
[SNORING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh hey Suzie.
So how did that Xcode
project for out for you?
SUZIE: Well, thanks
to Pod Try, I
was able to try out Core Plot.
But Mark and I decided it wasn't
quite right for us right now.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, you
know, that's understand.
Integrating a
third party library
is a serious step in your
developer relationship,
and not one you
should take lightly.
SUZIE: That's true.
Oh, and it reminds me.
I'm pregnant.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]